aussi bizarre que ça puisse paraître ça
a été un des plus beaux basset artésien
normandie soit seulement maintenant il
ya onze ans il maladie fait de l'oedème
cardiaques et les normes bidon il court
les poubelles évidemment physiquement ça
décuple le beau jeune homme qui l'a été
vers 11 ans vont là on a été chercher
avec mon ami jean rochefort un matin du
côté de soissons à l'élevage des rameaux
de cuisine et ça fait 11 ans qui nous
suit enfin qui vit avec moi qui viens
sur les tournages
il ya depuis l'an dernier un peu
maintenant il reste ici parce que c'est
tournage du son un peu pénible
sinon il a tout connu enfin il est venu
surtout les films même dans lexandre le
bienheureux jouer avec un autre chien il
était un peu jaloux parce que l'eau
c'est un petit et paris faisait la
tronche et c'est un grand bout de 1,6
quand je pars tourner maintenant que je
le laisse
et je reviens il a un première réaction
de contentement conjointe mais tout de
suite après il se reprend et il tourne
le nom pendant 24 heures ou 48 heures
fait la tronche je trouve c'est très
important d'avoir une femme âgée
toujours aimé les chiens si vous des
jeux progrès une chose pour laquelle
cette importance pour les enfants
ma fille avait 4 ans et demi quand on
l'a eu
un jour elle faisait une colère était
assise par terre à pleurer preppy ni un
peu comme pour les enfants et celui là
il y avait trois mois s'est déplacé
d'une son son lit est lui monté dessus a
léché ses larmes ça s'avère pendant de
la comtesse de ségur ça avait l'air
d'une blague mais depuis ce moment là
évidemment ça a été la moue l'amour
indéfectible et on a assez n120 aller
après qu'un homme voilà tu as bien
travaillé est doucement vache à lait
mais une brutalité là non c'est tout
c'est un chien que j'avais d'humour je
lui en parle ou pas ces objets des morts
j'espère qu'on va le conserver encore un
moment plus de la bouffe qui compte 1
t'as pas honte
hélas jamais chasser mais c'était un bon
chasseur et une fois derrière en forêt
de marly l'aï la course et pendant
quatre ou cinq heures des biches est
revenue exténué se coucher pendant 24
heures surtout qu'il arrivait de paris
n'avait jamais connu ça mais il n'avait
pas lâché
voilà très bien connaissez bande
dessinée snoopy
mais il est très proche de sa enfin je
crois que le le dessinateur de snoopy a
dû avoir soit bill soit un bas c'est
comme ça on joue là retour parce que ils
ont façon de se comporter bien
particulière j'ai bien qu'on fait
toujours un peu d'anthropomorphisme au
sujet des chiens de leurs réactions de
leurs mimiques mais je crois que là
c'est pas extrapoler de penser que
souvent il y avait des expressions tout
à fait proche de l'homme est assez rare
d'ailleurs lançant que ça l'ennuie
prodigieusement certainement tout ce que
nous faisons